so I was recently at the Google
zeitgeist conference and I was riveted
by a talk on the power of female
education and the speaker says
interesting line if you change the
prospects of an adolescent girl on a big
enough scale you will transform
societies in this hyper connected world
we cannot lose sight of the feminine
force that graces our planet and lives
beyond the earth in the stratosphere
throughout history women have broken
boundaries and transformed societies
Rosa Parks Marie Curie Indira Ghandi
Mother Teresa where would we be if these
women had been denied their basic right
to education when you educate a girl you
educate a nation Malala captivated our
hearts and minds when she bravely stood
up for her right to education but little
girls should not have to risk their life
for this the cost of excluding girls is
high in Uganda for example 85% of girls
leave school early resulting in 10
billion dollars in lost potential
earnings by delaying child marriage and
early birth for girls countries like
Bangladesh could potentially add sixty
billion dollars to the national income
over these girls lifetimes investing in
young girls can accelerate the fight
against poverty inequality and gender
discrimination there's overwhelming
evidence overwhelming evidence that
girls education is the most consistent
driver of development goals business as
usual is not enough and so on this day
as we celebrate International Girl's Day
let us put out that message empower
women educate women connect women
leverage emerging technologies bring
them together to create a network where
the Sacred Feminine can bring that voice
to cause a ripple in the global
conversation the next time you see a
little girl just think she could be the
next person to change the course of
history